that's a very simple point I've been
trying to make is that I think Perry's
denial of top death at that sort of
top-down bottom-up picture is should be
the basis of all attempts to account for
merchants is perfectly compatible with
the view that parts of physics are our
fundamental right it seems just true of
the sociology in history time that if a
special science most special sciences
are if they're related at all to each
other we're not quite sure how to relate
it to each other but whenever a conflict
and so with conflicts can emerge between
special Sciences and there's no the
empirical work will have to sort it up
but when a special science contradict
fundamental physics it's the special
science that has to chip that has to be
changed right but there's no reason you
don't have to Darwin was very worried
about kelvins that privacy aim about the
age of the Sun and the amount of energy
that's primacy of physics claim that
fact that physics drops fundamental
physics Trump's that perfectly
compatible with the idea that it doesn't
require us to suppose that it's because
physics describes a bedrock level right
and then there are other levels stacked
on top of it physics it's in fundamental
physics just is it seems to me the study
of those universal constraint did apply
everyone might help if we had a simple
toy model of what we're saying doesn't
happen and it occurs to me a nice
example might be think about the rules
of chess and think about somebody who
tries to derive the rules of chess from
the physics of chess pieces moving
around I think now no Queen goes on our
own color jeans and they're trying to
figure out what affinities there are and
trying to devise that from physics or
the you know the castling rule and they
finally throw up their hands and say
these are deep regularities but they're
at their own level
they don't reduce to the desktop reduce
to physics now you can imagine somebody
having a view about biology or any of
the or sociology which is the view that
as it turns out
there are the rules of the game in these
higher Sciences that just wad er and and
maybe there's a historical explanation
of how they came to be the rules but
even those aren't really going to be
explicable in terms of the underlying
physics that at least gives us a model
of what I think none of us accept we all
think that whatever good sense of
emergence there is there's no there's
nothing that is a principle like that
it's always going to emerge from from
physics I think but I think we can do
better than being on history's argue for
what we're referring to as the
microscopic or more fundamental level
being more comprehensive and the
macroscopic level but I think it meant
you know maybe part of the
contentiousness comes in and using words
like explain or because what we talk
about the relationships between these
different levels I think it it's on the
one hand plausible and apparently true
that you can have these macroscopic
regularities that could have been
exactly the same and equally true with
very different microscopic underlying
substrates and therefore in some sense
may be exactly that sense deserve to be
thought of as independent rules but it's
also true that there is this more
comprehensive theory that has a wider
domain of applicability with the feature
that in the region of that microscopic
theory that overlaps with the
macroscopic theory the microscopic
theory entails the macroscopic Theory
you could have thermodynamics and many
other substrates but once you know what
the stroke substrate is you're we're
going to have thermodynamics you are not
going to have anything else and I think
that we can stop there I don't think
it's Vanessa I mean I have many times in
the past I understand the desire to say
now we have explained the macroscopic
regularities but what if we didn't say
that well it changed I mean both levels
exist and are interesting to talk about
and it's if we're sticking to
understanding what happens in the world
I think you can just say that
and then use for our sort of personal
motivational purposes whether or not
that counts as an explanation or a
justification or a more fundamental or
whatever well when you say once we have
the this level the microscopic level we
have thermodynamics
that's just another way of rephrasing
the thermodynamics is entailed by the I
like the word entail but then when so
saying that is Phi I wouldn't argue with
that but maybe there's daylight in
between saying that and saying the
reason why thermodynamics is true is
because of the underlying autonomy I
don't see yeah I don't see any daylight
you